the City of Jacksonville Florida is
seeing record flooding millions in that
state are still without power and now
tropical storm Irma is bringing its
devastation to the state of Georgia on
the ground tonight in Columbus Georgia
our friend Fox News correspondent at
large I have no idea we got down there
or Aldo Rivera Geraldo what's going on
hey Shawn to tell you how I got down
here we landed in Charlotte North
Carolina believe it or not that was the
closest airport then we drive down to
Augusta Georgia from Augusta Georgia to
Atlanta Georgia is where what is now
tropical storm Irma was really visiting
it's Wrath trees were down about every
quarter of a mile there's a great big
tree across the road all the way to
Atlanta Atlanta
Hartsville Airport the big airport the
world's busiest hopelessly disrupted
today thousands of flights canceled
Southwest had no flights Delta just a
handful they canceled over 3,000 of
their flights the rapid transit in
Atlanta was closed all day today Monday
now we're down in Fort Benning the
sprawling army base that straddles the
Georgia Alabama line tropical storm Irma
passing through here now this is the
back side of the storm not much going on
before I talk to the garrison commander
we were at the Chattahoochee River where
there was tremendous flooding back in
the day 1990s then in 2009 hurricane
Irma came by and really visited some
some real wrath on the on the peach tree
on the peach tree State now you have a
situation where here in Fort Benning
they are gearing up to help in the
relief effort before we get there at the
Chattahoochee River you won't believe
what we saw we interviewed mayor Theresa
Tomlinson her town of 200-thousand
Columbus Georgia 30,000 of the the folks
in town have lost their power but as we
were doing an interview with the mayor
here while you watch here is a mayor
Tomlinson we're about in the eye of the
storm right now we really have gotten to
where we got past the northern part and
it was about 40 50 mile-an-hour winds
there we were taking about seven inches
of rain but the bottom half
storm Irma has sheared off and I think
we might have caught a break I saw two
knuckleheads actually jumping in the kya
and the Chattahoochee River there and
swimming through the rapids well and
you're right they are knuckleheads
that's very dangerous Rapids those are
class-three Rapids at this point
probably much higher than that because
of the volume and they they were very
much in danger but they luck was with
them this evening they got out looks
like your first responders very much on
the job we have a swift water rescue
team here obviously with class 4 class 5
Rapids on the other side of the river
here we have to have that every now and
then there's a foolish person or two and
they have to come get them out of the
river
this is Colonel Klink cockies the
garrison commander here at Fort Benning
over 100,000 military personnel and
civilians are at this base on a regular
basis we haven't seen each other since
the Kuwait when you were Ameer captain
so usually you know the military is not
involved in in you know domestic affairs
like storms and so forth but you are all
geared up how does it feel to be a first
responder in a sense this is what we we
do we protect the American people every
single day so whether that's on foreign
Souls or here domestically this is what
we do so we've been designated by FEMA
as a incident support base and we will
be ready to receive all of the
supporters that are going to head down
to Florida to help take care of the
folks down there so thoughts on 911 well
today is our day of remembrance the good
thing about the storm was we were able
to be home with our families for a lot
of us to remember about those things we
all know we had a lot of things
scheduled today run
we had a luncheon a prayer luncheon this
afternoon wiped out got wiped out by the
weather but at least we had folks home
with their families and they are all
safe and sound and all accounted for
today so Shaun I know you've got a round
robin of some of our brave reporters but
the tropical storm is heading into
Alabama and then you know going all the
way I think up to Indiana but you have
strong trekkers a lot for our expertise
then and I wish you were here we could
have visited your home then in Florida
together I hope all is well with you
Sean all
good by the way why does Geraldo always
have a police car next to him with a
lights with an around but listen in this
case it's to keep the traffic from
killing me that's probably true listen
we please tell all our friends all these
people that that sacrifice offer their
professionalism their training expertise
we really thank them they've done
amazing worth work both in Texas in
Florida we can't thank these guys enough
and on the 16th anniversary of 9/11 and
the five year anniversary of Benghazi
all those people all those heroes it
shows how great this country can be
Geraldo thank you Roger that Sean